sur son compte twitter anne vignot
annonce vouloir accueillir des réfugiés
afghans par devoir d'humanité quand on a
un peuple qui vit dans un moment
critique aigu comme l'afghanistan et
bien il est normal que nous nous posions
la question du droit d'asile voilà tout
simplement les écologistes disent nos
valeurs c'est une valeur humaniste et
non comme on exerce son opposition
municipale critique déjà la forme de
cette prise de position un tweet n'est
pas à la hauteur de la situation selon
laurent croizier du modem formule
cavalière d'après ludovic magaud des
républicains il lui reproche aussi de
n'avoir pas consulté l'opposition même
par un simple coup de fil et puis sur le
fond ils ne sont pas d'accord avec la
maire écologiste
ce ne sont pas les mères écologistes qui
sont décideurs de la politique étrangère
de la france ni de la politique
d'accueil des réfugiés et que
l'humanisme n'a pas de couleur politique
accueillons à besançon ce que nous
sommes en capacité d'accueillir et mais
par contre disputons travaillons en
concertation avec les services de l'état
qui eux vont avoir une vision globale de
l'accueil à l'échelle du pays ses
opposants l'accusent d'être resté
militante il juge qu' anne vignot et les
autres maires écologistes ont tenté un
coup médiatique une récupération
politicienne elle ne peut pas s'exprimer
en tant que militante
avec des peu des coups politiques la
france il ya un gouvernement qui ont
apprécié qu'on apprécie pas je suis pas
là pour pour juger de cela il ya un
phénomène très important à l'échelon
international et besançon qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je vous dise c'est
l'europe qui va traiter tout ça c'est la
communauté internationale qui malgré des
pointes à l'europe justement depuis 2018
chaque année 50 mille afghans sont
arrivés en europe et y ont demandé
l'asile politique